you've been real bad you've been bad
real bad well seems like their sin
follows
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know what to do with you I don't
know what's going on I don't even know
what to think of you guys I don't even
know what the thing so disappointed
can't believe it can't believe it
can't believe it
I just can't believe it
[Music]
happy 25 mil oh happy 25 million
subscribers everybody hey how you doing
also where the hell have I been what the
hell have I been doing I don't know
you're all grounded cuz you knew to cut
that [ __ ] out what would that what the
hell were you thinking getting me a
person like me 225 million why would you
do that that seems completely illogical
so you went wrong they're number one
number two how dare you frankly just how
dare you you think you think that you
think that I will tolerate you people
you you you subscribing to my content
when I don't even upload it what I don't
even upload what's wrong with you do you
know me look I'm not even the same human
I'm this has changed if you haven't been
able to tell if you're like looking at
me and you're like oh wait something's a
little bit off yeah I'm different and
I've changed and instead of thanking you
guys for 25 million subscribers which I
guess any other youtuber would know no
that's not how I do I'm gonna berate you
and I'm going to ground you I'm taking
away your phone listen I don't want any
sass back you have lost your phone
privileges hand it over to sand it over
put it in my PA box or whatever and you
go to your room go to your room go to
your room get out of here go to your
room right now I don't even want to hear
any sass I don't hear any sass don't
give me any of that No oh you sub twice
oh okay
alright sure yeah look I'm not even able
to upload properly probably because I'm
trying to upload on my laptop so if say
someone were near my laptop that was
hearing my words might want to like slam
that closed
I might might be able to help I'm
dropping frames like you wouldn't even
believe I'm dropping frames over here so
if that was like
an option for someone to do that maybe
someone could do that I'm just saying
it's it's entirely possible oh you're in
your room all right okay all right well
all right good good good you learned
your lesson still dropping frames man
this is good this is uh there's like the
worst celebration ever in the history of
forever maybe we've stopped dropping
frames maybe the connection is smoothed
down a little bit maybe it's good over
there hi hello yes I have been away but
I have many things to tell you guys
because I have not talked to you in a
while for various reasons I've been
literally shoving as much sour food in
my mouth as possible and trying to
destroy myself by tasing myself in
different ways but yes 25 million
subscribers happen today
Jase Crisis Blues a lot harder to blow
than I thought
my blowing skills need a lot of work no
I'm still dropping frames like you
wouldn't believe what somebody save the
Internet if somebody could save
oh my god I'm gonna die huh move okay if
somebody could save the Internet it's
literally anybody chica chica save my
frames
ah I'm still dropping frames like for
nobody's business this is the greatest
celebration stream that anybody has ever
seen in their goddamn life listen I do
have some actually pertinent information
to tell you guys about but I'm gonna try
to wait until all I'm dropping so many
frit could you save the Internet I'm
dropping frames like you wouldn't
believe is my laptop open or something
can you just slap that closed or
something like that okay hi chicas here
hey chica chica come here come here girl
come on come up here chica come here
come here cheek up up up
put up your dukes come on up up there
she there she is hi hello everybody my
name is markiplier still dropping frames
but you know I hope that'll pass soon
the Internet's just not cooperating with
me as well as it should
however chicas sure to make you all
better
ain't there right little girl ain't
there right you sweet pea you sweetest
you sweetums bleep owns you sweetie
people you good girl look at this good
girl getting better oh hell yeah it is
oh hell yeah it's not
oh it is Oh are we getting better are we
better okay good
oh good hi how you doing everybody
welcome to the celebration stream for 25
million subscribers first off I have
some I will get to the pertinent
information just as soon as things
generally kind of stop being insane let
me turn the music down a little bit here
yes she gave the adorable pups I'm so
happy to have her in my life and yes it
seems like the internet is clearing up
now so where have I been
I haven't uploaded in three days I might
as well be dead right but not the case
don't make me take away your tablet too
no you listen to me you gotta listen
when I'm talking I I had to put myself
in purgatory I shaved I cast shame on my
face and I had to no it's not it at all
what happened is I am busy which is
something that I have said many times
before but I have been exceptionally
busy and the things that I have been
busy with not all of it I am ready to
share with you guys but some of it I'm
ready to tell you guys about because you
guys are awesome and heck 25 million
subscribers is as good acts and excuses
any two tried to talk about something
but also cheers this is a this is
mineral water not a beer so I can't
exactly celebrate with alcohol listen
I'll take your switch I'll take your
tablet you misbehavior I gotta crack
down on that won't tolerate it note all
right none first thing I got to put up
my decorations that you'll never be able
to see because it's pitch boy yeah
yes sure my hair I didn't think this
through there we go okay so this is the
25 subscriber ballsack I have on my head
happy 25 million everybody okay so yeah
I've not been uploading for the past
three days because obviously I'm a tear
swear to God
because obviously I'm a terrible
youtuber who can't even tape a goddamn
balloon in my head like an [ __ ]
because I've been working on about a
bajillion things you guys know how I
like do too many things at once and I'm
not able to focus on it and for some
reason that comes back to haunt me and
and you know suddenly I can't do
anything because I I overcome it and
then you know not able to do anything
you guys know that you guys know that
about me have you learned that about me
just yet maybe maybe maybe not
yeah probably probably not okay okay now
that I got my ballsack all set up and
ready to go
I've been busy I've been very very very
busy
the first thing obviously that I've been
busy with his unas honest but I'm not
here to talk to you about ooh miss
honest I've already talked to you guys
about him and it's honest if you're not
part of honest honest yet frankly the
ship has sailed it's already gone if
you're not on the boat it's leaving the
station so I'm not gonna talk to you
guys about that I just have been busy
making content for that I've also been
busy because I've been trying to get
ahead on videos on this channel because
I don't like not uploading that's not a
thing I like contrary to popular those
things really stupid contrary to popular
belief of what many people might think
is I actually don't like not uploading
things I enjoy making videos and lately
I've been enjoying making videos
more than anything it has just been a
really like satisfying experience for me
in terms is just like creating on the
internet which is weird you know weird
right I'm supposed to be burnt out at
this point but to be perfectly honest
I've been making so much stuff lately
even today I just had this like brain
wave where I was like oh my god for this
project that I'm working on that I can't
tell you guys about yet but I was like
oh my god it's perfect I can't wait for
that now that's gonna be great
but yes busyness is no excuse so yada
yada here's another promise that I'm
gonna get we had I'm not really
promising this to be like oh please
forgive me like whatever it's if I'm
busy I'm busy I'm having fun while I'm
doing it so that's what really matters
at the end of the day but I am getting a
week ahead because it is really [ __ ]
hard to do what you want to do if you're
not on top of the things that you're
doing while you're doing it so in
addition to be trying to like try to get
my life in order in terms of the
projects I'm working on I'm also trying
to get my life in order in terms of just
my life like trying to get in a regular
schedule trying to get out of bed in the
morning as soon as I wake up trying to
stay on top of like the things that I
try to accomplish on a day-to-day basis
trying to get writing done what I can
squeezing it in where where it isn't
where it does but this is one of those
things see 25 million subscribers I I
haven't really been celebrating a lot of
milestones lately just because in a big
way
the numbers are not important
they really aren't and and for all of
you budding youtubers out there and all
of you want to be success on social
media I would encourage you not to
really focus on the numbers yes I'm
amazing I have 25 million subscribers
look how big my subscriber dick is it's
so huge its massive this balloon is
representative of my ego by the way this
this is the weight I have to bear when
I'm swinging my dick around when I got
my ego getting in the way of
things that I got to do but I would I
would I would suggest that you guys
don't really worry about the numbers as
much but that being said I do want to
celebrate it because you guys are the
reason that I'm able to make the things
that I want to make and I haven't just
said thank you lately you know and I've
always made a big a big stink about
saying thank you and and to be perfectly
honest I think the reason I've fallen
out of it is because I was in a rut for
so long I was in a rut I was gonna I
wasn't a real stinker of a rut I was I
was you know I hit around like 18 or 17
million and I just started to wonder
like okay what am i what do I do now and
you've probably heard this a million
times before from other youtubers and
such but for me like I've talked about a
little bit here and there but I was in a
real rut so like I started to shy away
from the the concept of thanking you
guys for every single milestone because
they felt less and less special each
time but right now I'm in like such a
good place you know and I I hate to just
say that and actually now I don't hate
to say it at all I'm very happy to say
that I'm gonna flaunt it in your face
how much fun I'm having but you know I'm
in a really good place so I'm not gonna
get emotional about it I'm not gonna get
big weepy about it but just seriously
like thank you guys thank you for
sticking with me for so long thank you
for being with me through this journey
I've apparently for some reason I've
discovered lately I have a long way to
go left on the things that I want to
make and I've got a ton of other things
that I want to do with what I'm doing so
if there's a reason for this emergency
family meeting which is definitely an
emergency it definitely called for a
crisis let me put the crisis music back
on and wait hang on wait
no that wasn't impactful
you've been real bad you're in trouble
now
if you're just joining this and you
didn't hear my speech for 30 minutes
straight of all the trouble that you're
in you're in for a surprise
because it's about to get really real
your phone gone the internet plan gone
tablet gone your switch smashed
everything gone books gone food gone ice
cream have gone sprinkles
gone skateboard gone scooty do gone
rawski it's gone
tick-tock gone Vine already gone YouTube
go on
it still goes I could know Milan alright
whatever um birthday cake gone Godzilla
gone the aliens gone they've judged
Justin they found us wanting
Xbox gone all right cool good now that I
got that away a what was that even the
[ __ ] oh yeah the reason I'm calling this
emergency family meeting is I I just I
haven't been able to thank you guys in a
while so just seriously thank you guys
and in going forward talking about the
great future of what YouTube is all
about and the things that I have to do
I am currently knee-deep in three
separate projects at the moment three I
am literally in the middle of three
different big projects but I do have
news should I say you know I won't say
yeah I should say I'm gonna give you
something just something to look forward
to I yeah [ __ ] it whatever I don't know
I don't like keeping secrets I think
it's stupid
I pitched the sequel for a heist with
markiplier and so look forward to that
in about a [ __ ] year cuz that's how
long it takes to make those things okay
cool I said that so that's cool look
forward to but that's not the main thing
that I wanted to talk about anyway it's
not even the important thing that I was
going to talk about okay so yay that's
cool also a heist with markiplier that
was only like God that was like four
four five it's like three months in a
few days wait no it's February now
January 5th December 5th November 5th oh
my god I feels like it's been half a
year since that came out it's only been
so little have you guys been visiting
Yancy I can't believe it oh my god um so
yeah holy crap
that that's a thing I pitched the idea
is so nice like it was so nice they were
so nice they loved it they freaking
loved it and they let you know why they
loved it here's that here's the kicker
you know why they loved ice with
markiplier is because you guys loved it
that was the amazing thing they they
they were practically kissing me on the
mouth when I walked in there I hope none
of them they were watching in this right
now they were not kissing me on the
mouth when I walked in the room that
would be sexual harassment and that's
not good they were not kissing me on the
mouth they were kissing me on the ass
very different no god are they watching
this Jesus Christ I forget sometimes
that this is public I went in there and
they were very happy about a heist with
markiplier and they were very happy
about the response that you guys had to
it and so like walking in there like I I
had an idea and I was ready to pitch it
but at the same time they were just like
holy hell man
you actually can make some [ __ ] and that
hit me like right here in my heart I
think it hit me and it was like a holy
[ __ ] some people actually recognize the
fact that I can make some stuff you know
like I even in my rut like I was I was
still making things but I was making
things just because I didn't know what I
was doing and you know what I discovered
about myself recently is that I'm not
happy unless I'm making things you know
what I mean
I'm not happy unless I'm doing something
I'm not happy unless I am pushing myself
real hard and now that I'm juggling all
of these different things that I'm doing
all at once I realized that I love it
but I'm only one dude I only got so much
time so I got to be as efficient as
possible about my time which is why
sometimes I don't upload a video on this
channel but that is gonna change because
this channel is not contrary to popular
belief this channel is not second fiddle
Donis honest I do not want people to
think that that is definitely not the
deal this is this is like my home and
that's why this is a family meeting it
all comes together you see you didn't
think I was gonna make it happen but I
did I don't know why I gotta feel like I
got to put my arms up like this I'm
trying to balance this balloon on my
head what did you miss are you just
coming in here now oh my god you've been
real bad I can't believe how bad you've
been I'm calling the police on your ass
you should have known better hand over
that phone your tablet hand it over
[Music]
you're never gonna make another dick
duck again you're never gonna tweet
you're never gonna make a gram post
you're not ever gonna make a story no
it's all going away
you're grounded you're grounded you're
grounded you're grounded three months
they're grounded you're grounded for
months try and sass me you're grounded
you're grounded five months you're
grounded
try me again push for six hi
No Limits you're grounded
this bit is so stupid god this is like
the dumbest bit I've ever done in my
life okay let's get back to the nice
booty oh wow [ __ ]
alright so yeah if you just joined in
you're grounded you're grounded for
allowing this schmuck 225 million
subscribers sooo yeah I've got a lot of
ambitious things coming out now this is
water
it's a topo Chico I actually I started
to drink these when I was in Austin
filming heist so yeah I just do them so
so yeah it's just like I I really
appreciate you guys sticking around and
I especially appreciate you guys having
the patience for me when I'm not able to
get content uploaded regularly but let
me be very clear this channel this
channel is my life and I love my life I
love what I do I love making content I
love making videos I that's all I think
about and I've got ideas for ambitious
other projects bigger things other
things that I want to do other things
that I want to accomplish but when it
comes down to it and I said I wasn't
gonna get sappy but I feel like I gotta
give them do a little sappy [ __ ]
territory here is when it comes down to
it I always want to recognize the fact
that it boils down to you guys being
there for me and in return I want to be
there for you and I know that's hard to
do through a camera lens I know it's
hard to do through the internet but
honestly and truly this channel means
the world to me and you know I'm not
saying that like it's gonna last forever
but I haven't such
like creative mood lately I just
freaking love making [ __ ] it's it's been
exciting a newness honest has been like
a big driving force behind it but it's
leaching into everything else
like I said I'm like the sequel for
heist is is going forward who knows when
that's gonna be made I'm very busy but
I've got two other big things that I'm
working on hopefully one of those you
might hear about soon depending I'm
always changing things and the other one
I have no idea where that's gonna even
go but like I love it I really love it
and I have you guys to thank for it so
with that being said you're still
grounded but hey I'm proud of you
because it's not me
hidden 25 million that means there's 25
million of you that have decided to
subscribe to this [ __ ] [ __ ] and
that is a brave brave thing if you if
you manage to override your common sense
and subscribe to me you are brave brave
purse okay cool good there was probably
something else important that I was
gonna mention I've completely forgotten
I didn't write anything down before I
was talking but I'm gonna leave it on
that I'm gonna leave it on that thank
you guys so much for being here with me
expect more content soon wring the
goddamn bell if you want to know and if
you don't want to know I don't know it's
to stay the course continue on whatever
you doing a it's your life everyone else
is telling you to ring the bell why
should I so you know just if you want to
see the [ __ ] that I'm making stay tuned
oh dear god oh god social media yeah I
haven't been on social media at all
because it pisses me off most of the
time that's why so I haven't been doing
much social media
hey you know that's okay you know got it
not even me
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for 25 million
subscribers this hereby concludes our
emergency family meeting I hope you get
your [ __ ] sorted out I don't want to see
it happen again but hey just cuz I'm
disappointed in you doesn't mean I don't
love you okay you stay frosty champ take
care of yourselves take care of each
other and as always I'll see you in the
next video